data science is a desired profession
that brings together diverse skills
needed to handle data and turn it into
useful information industries are
relying on scientific discoveries about
biology and translating the basic
understanding of biological processes
into useful insights for many tasks like
drug discovery improved treatment
efficacy as well as early detection of
risks and even anticipation of disease
progression these data intensive
applications offer a deeper look at
what's going on and require
computational analysis skills that today
can be learned by anyone engineer or
biologist
in this program we will cover practical
and conceptual aspects of machine
learning and application to high
throughput biomedical data using various
data analysis tools r and python
throughout the course students will get
an understanding of opportunities and
limitations of machine learning in the
context of basic and translational
biomedical research projects for
pre-clinical and clinical applications